und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend dass die Männer der
iranischen Nationalmannschaft ein
Zeichen setzen durch das nicht Singen
der Nationalhymne das immerhin konnte
die FIFA nicht verhindern zum Thema Iran
kommen wir gleich noch ausführlicher
schauen aber erstmal auf den heute
eskalierten Konflikt zwischen einer
Reihe europäischer Verbände und der FIFA
Führung
Präsident Gianni Infantino hatte ja mal
davon geschwärmt welche unglaubliche
Erfahrungen mit dieser WM einhergehen
würden in der Tat unglaublich ist hier
vieles wie Stefan Bier Bericht
Englands Kapitän Harry Kane hätte der
erste sein soll und doch daraus wurde
nichts die Armbinde der
Mannschaftsführer mit der one
love-botschaft gegen Homophobie und
anderes Unrecht wurde vom
internationalen Fußballverband
kurzerhand verboten beim Deutschen
Fußballbund ist man zerknirscht aber
machtlos
die FIFA hat heute eine Aussage für
Diversität und Menschenrechte untersagt
das sind Werte zu denen sie sich in
ihren eigenen Statuten verpflichtet
das ist aus unserer Sicht mehr als
frustrierend und auch ein beispielloser
Vorgang in der WM-Geschichte wie ich
finde
Innenministerin Nancy Fehse für den
Sport zuständig erreichte die Nachricht
den Ankara
so untersagt wird finde ich nicht in
Ordnung finde ich sehr befremdlich und
finde es auch alles andere als gut dass
es jetzt wieder einmal auf den Rücken
der Sportler ausgetragen wird denn die
FIFA drohte für den Fall einer
Zuwiderhandlung mit sportlichen
Konsequenzen das hätten persönliche
Strafen gerne gelbe Karte etwa für
Manuel Neuer oder auch Punkt Abzüge sein
können ein Messer auf der Brust es fühlt
sich schon stark nach Zensur an und ähm
man kann es natürlich die Binde nehmen
ja aber die Werte für die wir stehen die
werden wir haben und die werden auch
immer wieder zum Ausdruck bringen dazu
hat der DFB eine Reihe von Aktionen
nehmen Kata angekündigt auch anderswo
herrscht Unverständnis
wir haben mit der Armbinde schon
gespielt in europawettbewerben der UEFA
deshalb mit der WM nichts zu tun ich
sehe das Problem nicht
die FIFA macht sich mit ihrer WM in
Katar weiter unbeliebt jeden Tag ein
bisschen mehr
die Iraner hingegen zeigten sich heute
auf ihre Weise beherzt und vereint das
kein Spieler bei der iranischen
Nationalhymne mit Sang ist ein Zeichen
dass ihre Fans im Stadion genauso
wahrnamen wie ihre Landsleute zu Hause
auch wenn das iranische Staatsfernsehen
dieses Szene bei der Live-Übertragung
abbrach
und auch wenn die katarischen
Veranstalter ganz im Sinne Teherans
dafür sorgen dass iranische Fans mit
regimekritischen Fahnen T-Shirt
aufdrucken oder ähnlichem möglichst
unsichtbar bleiben
die alte persische Nationalflagge
Protest einer Frau ohne Kopftuch auf den
Ringen in Katar vor dem Stadion
Polizeieinsatz obwohl hier die Flagge in
der Hosentasche schon verschwunden ist
das ist die wirkliche persische Flagge
nicht das hier das ist doch die
islamische
sie nutzen die Aufmerksamkeit um das
iranische Gewaltregime vor aller Welt
anzuklagen
darum sind wir hier als Stimme unseres
Landes unser Volk kämpft gerade für
Menschenrechte dieses Regime schießt auf
Kinder auf Studenten in den Straßen es
ist unglaublich
was es heißt mit Steinen und Knüppeln
gegen eine hochgerüstete Staatsmacht zu
protestieren erlebten heute Tausende im
kurdischen Nordwesten Irans das Regime
geht mit gewehrsalben gegen sie los
in Javan Ruth in Piranha in machabat mal
gezielt mal wahllos abgefeuert auf
unbewaffnete Menschenrechtsgruppen
sprechen von mehreren Toten und
Verletzten genaue Zahlen gibt es nicht
inzwischen sind schwer bewaffnete
Militäreinheiten der Revolutionswächter
eingetroffen man werde so heißt es jetzt
verstärkt gegen separatistische
Terrorgruppen Vorgehen leider so
befürchten Experten nur der Auftakt zu
noch mehr Blutvergießen das ist noch
schlimmer werden kann ist die eigentlich
die Logik des Regimes und wenn man die
Tradition rumänisch kennt wenn man die
die gewalttätige Tradition des Regimes
kennt dann müssen die eigentlich langsam
richtig zuschlagen und diese obwohl es
jetzt schon so schlimm ist
bereits gestern hatte Iran Ziele
jenseits der Grenze im kurdischen
Nordirak angegriffen hier kam mindestens
ein Menschen ums Leben in Teheran hieß
es heute dazu nur
Iran hat das Recht seine Grenzen und die
Sicherheit seiner Bürger zu schützen und
dabei auch Bedrohungen aus dem Ausland
abzuwehren
in Mahabad trauerten die Menschen heute
um die Opfer der anhaltenden Polizei
Gewalt
für Freiheit kämpfen und sterben sie
auch in der Ukraine Russland setzt den
Terror gegen die Zivilbevölkerung fort
mit der Bombardierung von Städten und
der Zerstörung von Stromversorgung und
Heizkraftwerken hinzu kommt die Sorge um
die Sicherheit von Atomkraftwerken
Svetlana Ullmann über die Lage der
Ukraine
schwarz räumt mit seiner Familie und
Nachbarn die Trümmer seines Hauses auf
gegen 2 Uhr morgens wachte ich auf um
ins Bad zu gehen kurz danach gab es eine
Explosion und ist zerbarsten alle
Fenster
entfernt liegt das Atomkraftwerk
sapurichia es war am Wochenende Ziel von
dutzenden Explosionen seit März ist das
größte Atomkraftwerk Europas auf
ukrainischem Boden in russischer Hand
erstmals wurde es gezielt bombardiert
und die Stromversorgungsleitungen zu den
letzten noch Energie erzeugenden Blöcken
5 und 6 beschossen ein
iaa-team hatte heute das Gelände
besichtigt und Entwarnung gegeben was
wir gehört haben aus den Meldungen der
irr wurden einige nebeneinrichtung
beschossen ein Lager für radioaktiver
Abfälle das Lager für die frischen
Brennelemente die Stromversorgung der
Blöcke 5 und 6 und einige andere
Einrichtungen noch man muss dazu sagen
dass der Beschuss bisher keinen Einfluss
auf die nukleare Sicherheit der Anlage
gehabt hat dennoch die Hoffnung der
Ukrainer die Reaktoren wieder über den
Winter hochfahren zu können und die
Energieversorgung zu verbessern sind
zerstört worden Präsident selenski
spricht bei Zoom bei der NATO in Madrid
von einem sabotage-aktarossen
alle unsere Nationen brauchen einen
garantierten Schutz vor russischen
raketenunversabotageakten anatomanlagen
rosa Tom die russische Energiebehörde
bezichtigt wiederum die Ukraine und
waren vor atomaren Zwischenfällen wer
tatsächlich dafür verantwortlich war ist
momentan nicht prüfbar
IAEA-Chef Raphael grossi forderte aber
alle eindringlich auf wer auch immer
dahinter steckt es muss sofort aufhören
und für Familie Quarz bedeutet der
Beschuss am Wochenende zusätzlich dass
sie jetzt im Winter kein sicheres zu
Hause mehr haben werden
auch andere Länder fühlen sich von
Russland unmittelbar bedroht die kleine
Republik Moldau etwa die Moskau mit dem
Entzug von Energielieferungen die
stabilisieren will damit geht es jetzt
in den Nachrichten weiter Heinz ja um
der Republik Moldau zu helfen gab es in
Paris eine weitere internationale
unterstützerkonferenz Frankreichs
Präsident macron sagte dabei heute
Hilfen von rund 100 Millionen Euro zu
Deutschland trägt laut Außenministerin
baerbock weitere rund 32 Millionen
Deutschland setzt beim Ersatz für
russisches Pipeline Gas unter anderem
auf flüssig Erdgas das per Schiff
geliefert wird die Kosten für LNG
Terminals könnten nun gut dreieinhalb
Milliarden Euro höher liegen als geplant
vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hieß es
der Gesamtbedarf habe sich 2022 auf rund
6,5 Milliarden Euro an Haushaltsmitteln
erhöht
bei einem Erdbeben der Stärke 5,6 sind
den Indonesien mindestens 162 Menschen
ums Leben gekommen hunderte weitere
wurden verletzt das Epizentrum lag im
Westen der Insel Java zahlreiche Häuser
wurden durch das Beben zerstört vor den
Krankenhäusern warten verletzte um
behandelt zu werden einige Gebiete sind
aufgrund von Erdrutschen noch nicht
erreichbar
noch kurz zu den Wetteraussichten morgen
gibt es am Vormittag ganz im Norden bei
Schnee und Eisregen große Glätte Gefahr
er regnet wird es auch im Westen und
Südosten sonst bleibt es trocken die
Sonne zeigt sich aber nur selten die
Temperatur steigt der Fährte von 1 bis
10 Grad
das Wasser auch schon von uns in dieser
Halbzeitpause um 0 Uhr gibt es unser
heute schon Update mit Gundula Krause
und uns gibt es dann morgen wieder auch
wieder um 20:45 Uhr da spielt Frankreich
gegen Australien bis dahin auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]